so
walking the other day in part in the sky
was really
gray it was really really cool
lori brooks has found peace in painting
the colors are calming the strokes
soothing
but it's a temporary distraction from
the disease that started ravaging her
body
three years ago it felt like my whole
life
had been turned upside down and
backwards just
you know a picture of pulling the rug
out from underneath you
and kind of flopping around
it was it was hard and your first
thought is of course
am i gonna die in 2018 the mother of
four who lives in abbotsford bc
was diagnosed with advanced colon cancer
she endured surgery
months of chemotherapy and radiation but
a year later
it came back i was in a lot of distress
and just feeling like my life is over
and
i'm not going to get to see my kids get
married or have their own kids
and just that feeling of loss
just a stabbing pain and i could barely
breathe
and so i thought i can't live like this
the anguish led her to a different kind
of treatment
hallucinogenic medicine known as magic
mushrooms
did you think that this was going to
help you deal with dying yes
brooks says the six-hour experience was
like being in a dream
but she was awake a trip in her mind
where she suddenly found herself in a
forest
dark and scary at first but at the end
a light like oh i'm not alone in this
i have all these people in my life too
that are here for us and
i think it was more of that that just
the feeling
that i'm not alone that session was with
a therapist present
but underground technically magic
mushrooms are banned in canada
do you have any concerns about it being
illegal well what are they going to do
i'm a cancer patient
who's suffering are they going to throw
me in jail i doubt it
[Applause]
when daniel carcillo played with the
national hockey league
he was known as car bomb an enforcer he
was a fighter
and a menace on the ice at the age of 30
when his team the chicago blackhawks
was on a run of stanley cup wins number
13
walked away from the game there were too
many hits to the head
and he was diagnosed with traumatic
brain injury
i got to a point where i became hopeless
and very suicidal i was
extremely lost i had just cut off the
hockey community which is really the
only community that i knew
and i didn't know what to do next what
happened next was a trip to a mushroom
farm
where he learned about the compound that
makes the magic
psilocybin not only saved my life but
also helped me really reverse all of the
symptoms that i was suffering from today
carcillo doesn't recognize the man
he used to be the best healthiest
version of myself
turn on tune in
and drop out this is the version of
psychedelics
most people know synonymous with the
counter culture generation of the 1960s
but in the 50s in a small saskatchewan
city
on canada's prairies hallucinogenic
research was already underway
at the weyburn mental hospital
psilocybin
along with lsd was being used to treat
mental health issues
and alcoholism not only among patients
but among doctors and nurses too it was
here that the expression
psychedelics was first coined it's such
an interesting area of healthcare
because it does carry that cultural
baggage
dr evan wood is one of canada's leading
authorities on treating addiction
including how the war on drugs was a
setback cultural backlash
that led to essentially a total freeze
being put on research in this area
and really halting the science as well
so we're decades behind and we could
have been ahead of this
yeah it's a it's a sad state of affairs
and uh that's something that we probably
knew in the 1960s or 70s
so this is a small print that we took
from a mushroom that we grew in-house
this is the heart of research in canada
today
numinous a state of the art lab in
nanaimo bc
is growing millions of the rock star of
psychedelic mushrooms
cyloside cubensis lab workers are busy
extracting that crucial compound
psilocybin it's illegal to produce
possess
and sell psilocybin the active
ingredient in mushrooms
but numinus is the first company in
canada to have
legal permission to harvest this
hallucinogen
the company is about to begin clinical
trials on patients
so how do these mushrooms work on the
brain the brain has
all these pathways much like a highway
when a patient has a psychedelic
experience
different parts of the brain that
weren't connecting
now do this greater neuroplasticity
enhances the brain's ability to
reorganize thought patterns
which in turn helps those with
psychological disorders
to tap into different pathways for
dealing with their anxiety depression
pain or trauma and what psychedelics do
is they actually disrupt
the default mode network temporarily
taking it offline
in essence so that one can have an
experience that's different from being
trapped
in those same loops of thinking
dr devin christie wears two hats for
numinous medical doctor
and counselor she works with patients
who have chronic pain and trauma
a clinical treatment with psychedelics
can last up to eight hours
these medicines cause changes in our
brain
and in our perception that can be quite
profound
some examples are a sense of
timelessness or boundlessness
having mystical type experiences that
can be very spiritually significant or
meaningful
there can be visuals or
auditory senses or even something called
synesthesia when different senses blend
together in one's experience
outside a clinical setting it's clear
the future
is fungi canadians are consuming them in
pills
chocolate or tea but these products
contain
tiny amounts of magic mushrooms it's
called micro dosing
and this vancouver dispensary is seeing
a shroom
boom even if it's still technically
illegal
i don't know if you remember when
cannabis companies were first opening
and before they were fully regulated
we're kind of functioning in that gray
zone with micro dosing
the experience is less about a trip and
more about being able to focus the mind
how can you ensure that this is safe for
them our biggest thing is just like
teaching people what these medicines do
educating them on the dosage and the
protocols like essentially just trying
to get as much information out as
possible
so that people can make decisions for
themselves it's not just storefront
dispensaries
canadians who are looking for relief
from stress anxiety and depression
are turning to online sellers and
there's not much regulation in the gray
area of micro dosing
even daniel carcillo is getting into the
game
he now follows a weekly regimen of micro
dosing
and he's the founder of wesana health a
wellness company in chicago
testing the use of mushrooms to treat
anxiety and depression
in people with traumatic brain injury
it's a total conversion for carcillo
do you miss hockey
no not at all so excited to be doing
what i'm doing
and very grateful for all the suffering
that i went through in the nhl
and afterwards um so
you know in a way i can thank gary
bettman and thank the nhl for the
position that they've put me in you know
the suffering was definitely necessary
to get to a point of recovery
lori brooks is no longer suffering even
though her cancer has spread
she turned to mushrooms again to help
her prepare for the inevitable
she now has the support of a non-profit
group helping terminally ill canadians
legally access psilocybin
i was lucky enough to have
people in my life that were willing to
offer it to me but most people don't
and i can't imagine going through
cancer and everything just without that
help
the first time around she wanted to know
her family was going to be fine
this time she needed to know she was
going to be
okay i'm at the point now where i'm
just happy living my life and i'm at
peace
knowing that i'm most likely not going
to survive this
i'm just enjoying every day that i have